welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3
is revealing some interesting twists and
new trailer footage nothing too spoilery
but imagery we need to investigate to
figure out why French critics are
calling it the best Marvel movies since
end game I did not care for that beat
the power cows or the way from on the
talk to are you an ambassador so people
are Groot I I'm gonna break down the
fascinating new details and if anything
seems too spoilery I will save it for
the end and give you a warning also I
highly suggest you re-watch volume 1 and
volume 2 with me in a Guardians of the
Galaxy rewatch I am doing on the Deep
dive Channel Volume 2 analysis coming
this Friday and next week when volume 3
releases on May 5th I will do a live
breakdown in Q a with all of you okay
let's start with this promo released on
April 22nd with a Roundup of early
reviews from the European Premiere crank
up the volume
Guardians laugh out loud funny exactly
you idiot okay okay I know sometimes
these final days promos get a little
cringy with their sound bites and
critics in the editing that makes it
sound like the characters are
interacting with the quotes but these
promos aren't really for us we already
got our tickets these are really for
viewers and events who need a more
direct marketing appeal that's why this
promo is cut to Blue swedes Hooked on a
Feeling from the promos for the 2014
film the first ever movie soundtrack
with no original songs to hit billboard
number one they're trying to remind
everyone how awesome these Guardians
movies are so here we see Peter incamora
in an inner core of that fleshy facility
that we've seen in other trailer footage
with hoses of yellow fluid snaking in
and out of a tank behind them I have
been speculating that this could be the
same yellow Celestial brain fluid that
the collector was mining on nowhere the
Special Sauce that the high evolutionary
Herbert Windham might have used to give
his Creations like rocket human
consciousness there's also this new shot
of groot's fight with Adam Warlock in
nowhere Groot cocoons his branches
around Adam but Adam who has experienced
bursting out of cocoons himself blasts
upward we also hear the voice of
Rocket's past love the otter-like
creation of Lila it's good to have
friends to me that sounds like the voice
of Linda Cardellini who already plays
Laura Barton in the MCU but she worked
with James Gunn and Scooby-Doo films and
the film super gun actually confirmed
Cardellini is voicing Lila this morning
in an exclusive new clip via collider
with Michaela Hoover playing floor and
assim chaudry playing thiefs Lila
that's a pretty name Lila
thank you
I think my name shall be Thieves
because although we all do have them
mine are definitely the most prominent
thieves thiefs
me because floor because me is lying on
floor you're lying on a floor so your
name is floor yeah
foreign
what about you friend
Someday I'm gonna make great machines
that fly
and me and my friends are gonna go
flying together
into the forever and beautiful sky
Lila
thieves
and floor
and me
rocket we're still wondering which if
any of the Guardians might die in this
film but after Past trailer shots of
Peter Quill screaming over a medical
table a setting where another shot of
Groot included his screen with rockets
outlined we now see rocket sitting up on
the medical table very much alive so
that happened now that isn't to say
Rocket won't die in this movie or that
there might be something else going on
here but this is just a good example of
how trailers are often edited
deceptively and you can't always draw
firm conclusions from them I go more
into the specifics of how this works in
my deep dive on trailer deception and
the best way to support me doing that
kind of new invest story content and
just to grab one of these rocket science
shirts at nerd riot.shop in the Deep
dive collection now returning this
footage from the volume 2 post credit
scene Krueger returns using sorcery to
conjure a laugh Emoji now Kruger is a
Lem species in the comics he is sorcerer
Supreme in an alternate 31st Century
reality Earth 691 here he wears vest
with the ravager logo in a green stone
in the middle which might be his version
of the eye of agamoto also in the scene
Michael Rosenbaum Returns His Mark to
next stakar ogor's lieutenant and the
floating robot head of Mainframe who is
voiced by Miley Cyrus in the volume 2
post credit scene I miss you guys so
much and she'll presumably voice a
character here by the way the maroon
shirt that Peter wears has a blue orlony
on it those are the scoring rat
creatures the Guardians movies so to do
these breakdowns I'm on my Mac
constantly for work and the last thing I
need is a spinning beach ball of death
slowing me down that's why I use clean
my Mac X for me clean my Mac X is a
must-have tool whether my Mac is brand
new or 10 years old the app is made with
every Mac in mind clean my Mac X has a
ton of useful features the most
prominent is smart scan in which makes
sure no junk files are keeping my Mac
from running as fast as possible clean
my Mac X also comes with an uninstaller
to get rid of all the stuff apps can
leave behind when you delete the main
file I can also use space lens to
quickly and easily see which files are
taking up the most space on my system
the newest version of clean my Mac X
also lets me easily keep tabs on what's
going on with my Ram CPU external disks
and connected devices using the
redesigned menu app and whenever I'm not
sure which of clean my Mac X's Swiss
army knife set of tools would be best to
use next I just use the built-in
assistant to figure out what I need to
do to optimize my Max performance clean
my Mac X is the best way to get the most
out of your computer to get started
click the link in the description and
get a free 7-Day trial of clean my Mac X
today and trust me after using clear my
Mac for free for seven days you're gonna
love it as much as I do click the link
in the description below to start your
free 7-Day trial today now there were
also a few longer Clips released let's
take a look at this scene with quill
nebula mantis Jackson Groot on counter
Earth drags stay here with rocket watch
him that's who they're coming for Groot
you know what to do with these
push the button
got in
okay now what open the door whoa so this
is officially the first F-bomb of the
MCU James Gunn confirmed it will be
uncensored in the theatrical cut going
on to say how you can only have one in a
PG-13 movie and that he told Chris Brad
to add it on set and it made the moment
funnier so they kept it but that's a big
deal the MCU has never had f-bombs only
kind of these self-censored moments like
Peter Parker and Spider-Man no way home
or Nick Geary in the post credit scene
of Avengers Infinity War
now groot's bedroom and the volume two
post credit scene had few written on it
in the scroll language and James Gunna
said that many of his I am groots
throughout the movies have just been
versions of adjacent to the MCU we did
get that one famous one from Wolverine
and X-Men first Class excuse me an
American channels Xavier go [__]
yourself now we gotta say the VFX of
Groot in this scene look insanely good
it looks like a guy wearing a Groot suit
and it sounds like from their
conversation that rocket is here in this
residential house but it makes me
curious why we have not seen rocket in
any of the footage in the scene other
than shots where Gamora is carrying him
to safety fleeing from Adam Warlock
who's gonna attack them in this location
now another clip released to Rotten
Tomatoes includes Peter recapping the
events of infinity war and endgame to
Daniela melchior's character Yoda not
really sure the spelling there but
here's what happens we used to be in
love yeah she was my girlfriend only she
doesn't remember it because it wasn't
her because her dad threw off a magic
cliff and she died and then I lost my
temper and nearly destroyed half the
universe
and she came back out of the past there
she is
everyone else who died in the past
stayed dead not her why was it the magic
Cliff I don't know that's some freaking
infinity stone scientist
and some dumbass Earth dude who met a
girl fell in love
that girl died
and then came back a total dick ha it's
interesting that Peter Quill takes
responsibility for losing his temper and
punching Thanos out of mantis's trance
in that Dogpile during the Battle of
Titan and Avengers Infinity War because
they nearly did in that war in that
single moment and had Peter Quill not
punch Thanos half of all life would not
have been dusted also little detail here
I love how Peter tosses this orb and
catches it just like he did with the orb
in volume 1 that contained the Power
Stone when he was trying to look cool
but he dropped it so while Peter is
remembering the Infinity Stones In This
Moment he instinctively does the move he
did with the one infinity stone he held
okay another extended clip shows the
Guardians in those spacesuits that
totally look like the Among Us suits but
they are actually not to the suits in
2001 A Space Odyssey Peter tries to
profess his love to Gamora well what I'm
trying to say Peter you know this is an
open line right what we're listening to
everything you're saying and it is
painful and you're just telling me now
we were hoping I would stop on its own
but I switched it over to private what
color button did you push blue for the
blue suit oh no blue was the Open Line
for everyone oranges for blue what black
is for orange yellow is for green green
is for red and red is for yellow no
yellow is for yellow green is for red
red is for green I don't think so try it
though
you're right ah just some classic who's
on first style absurdism here based on
this insane color logic Peter is the
only one of them whose color yellow
matches his buttons so he's the only one
that they could easily yell at and get
the right person but before Peter to
talk privately to Gamora he would have
to punch orange which is mantis's color
the color of his half-sister also a
little detail I like how Drax wears the
red suit but it is accessed with the
green button Drax in the comics was
originally the color green now there's
another new shot of nebula in all these
promos showing her new metallic weave
arm turning it into a cannon Gunn
confirmed that this nanotech was built
for nebula by rocket to repay her for
her gifting him Bucky's vibranium arm in
the Guardians holiday special then on to
the last promo we will talk about here
which is released on IGN take a look
that is sad
you know what's sad people on Earth die
when they're like 50. are you about to
die I'm not 50
what you got issues quill oh come on
up
oh
my God so Peter's assessment of average
life expectancy is lower because his
mother died when she was young she was
probably in her 30s when that happened
but also remember Peter Quill as an
adult has not been on Earth for very
long and one Terran human that he saw
die was Tony Stark when Tony Stark was
in his 50s I would say life expectancy
was lower in the 80s but no it was 75 in
1988 when he was abducted and I hate to
bump people out but we're now at a point
in 2023 where life expectancy has gone
down which with things like the blip and
all the madness that happened afterwards
with all these Avengers Level Threats
life expectancy on the MCU Earth is
probably even lower but my favorite part
of this it's hard to see since Traxxas
invisible but as Drax slowly snacks in
the background when mantis asks if
Peter's about to die thinking that he's
around 50 years old tracks nods Now The
Last Detail I'm going to talk about is a
bit spoilery so feel free to stop
watching now thanks everybody but if you
stuck around you may have caught a quick
shot of the high evolutionary Herbert
Windham ship on a collision course with
nowhere so it looks as though the reason
the Guardians were set up with nowhere
as their new home in the Guardians
holiday special was to set up the this
climactic final battle in this familiar
setting furthering my thinking that
celestials and their goo are really at
the heart of this story okay so a
reminder Friday April 28th will be my
deep dive of Guardians Volume 2 followed
by Friday May 5th noon Eastern my live
breakdown in Q a a spoiler conversation
of Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 3. my
Easter egg breakdown to Volume 3 will
come out later that day on the main new
rockstars channel right here and again
please help me continue to grow the Deep
dive Channel by grabbing one of these
rocket science teas at nerd riot.shop
which has a ton of other great Guardians
the Galaxy inspired designs subscribe to
new rockstars on YouTube and on all
social platforms follow me at eavos
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
thank you